hey guys whoa hey guys I'm Ryan right
that's that's your cue
oh hi I'm Christopher Corbin nice to
meet you Chris Chris is new to the
channel first time here knew him from
ages ago he used to be like 800 pounds
and now he's like this that's not true I
was 200 pounds was my heaviest weight
and I think I looked pretty good back
then I think I look pretty good now to a
wardrobe change there you go so matters
gonna die soon so we gotta make this
fast
yeah so it's because Halloween this week
I just want to do a special talk about a
cool horror movie I watched again last
week Chris really seems to appreciate
the film a lot more online from dusk
till dawn Bam Bam Bam
dude that's I'm going Horror Nights on
Thursday and they have a dusk till dawn
titty bar maze from the that's gotta be
from there like to promote the show
though right that's run the show that's
like walking
yeah it's promote show but it's yeah
that's awesome no I'm excited to [ __ ]
see it I really appreciate that film a
lot cuz it's like the first half of that
film we're even like the two thirds of
that film
oh nothing to do with vampires
whatsoever no it's a turn what actually
like the ordinary world part if you
really think of it as a hero's journey
there's the ordinary world and then
there's the like turn part where you
actually get into the [ __ ] that come so
late into the movie yeah well you're
like the ordinary world these guys rob a
bank and like kidnap his family go to
make sure they're going to a bar and
then the [ __ ] turn is like oh [ __ ]
everybody's a vampire everybody's gonna
die but it's a great term because like
it does put you in those shoes yeah for
the characters it's so unexpected
oh yeah and so it happens in a really
unexpected way so it does add that
impact but even honestly like I do like
the vampire aspect but the first
two-thirds of the film I like actually
more than the vampire party I would say
that too because it just doesn't like it
actually has real feels like real life
like this it's just almost like just
watching a horror movie seeing these two
guys that are like kidnapping this
family and the sexual deviant the one
brother who's played by Quinn Tarantino
who does an amazing job yes like one
really good performance he's ever yeah I
was like he's actually so good as the
creepy pedophile guy and I'm like I
don't know why does it write that for
instance because before that he doesn't
like he did the Pope he did the little
piece of Mister doesn't miss your pink
right mr. Brown mr. brown
yeah that's right didn't want to be
called [ __ ] yeah I don't like this [ __ ]
and then he did a pulp fiction a little
like scene where he I had to wash the
hands which I love dead and we're
storage yeah dan Edwards storage and
then then he did from nothing docile
night and the other one mariachi
desperado desperado yeah and he was
really good just telling the joke and
then getting shot in the face but I
thought that team up for this one was so
good I wonder if he like knew he was
gonna be cast for that was specific role
because he went all out with the
creepiness I'm sure I mean the guy's a
serial killer rapist thief and like you
do feel all that I mean every once in a
while I do get the sense that Tarantino
was a little too aware of his own
dialogue yeah so sometimes it sounds a
little bit like very prepared
but overall though I think he does a
good job in the first time I saw this
movie I didn't really like this guy but
this last time I saw it I was like he
does a great job George [ __ ] Clooney
no he's fantastic in this movie man he's
a character I realize is not written at
all like a likable bad guy he's not
likable this guy like he's an [ __ ]
he's just he's a horrible human being
doesn't care about anyone else but
himself yet George Clooney managed to
still make a very unlikable person
likable because the script doesn't offer
much to make him likable at all he's on
edge the whole time but he's trying to
keep his cool together the entire time
there's very few actors who can pull off
that kind of badass dialogue so
consistently throughout a movie I feel
like he falls into these characters all
the time where he's like every character
he plays I'm like I like that guy I
really like that guy it doesn't matter
what he's doing it I think it'd be like
a psycho baby killer yeah but I feel
like you would be like you'd like in my
image somehow you find like yeah he's
just such a handsome good-looking the
over oh that famous moment where George
Clooney realizes that
yeah the Tarantino just raped a murder
the hostage hmm and then it just it's
just quick little flashes and that one
shot and then it's as quick little
flashes of the image
what's going on what happened yeah it's
brilliantly edited
I love the elephant the title credits
when the camera pans over from them in
the car to the woman in the trunk so
many neat things are just in this film
one bad thing you're not to mention is
for the camera dies yeah [ __ ] Asian
kid he's horrible
I bought the night what Asian kid Harvey
Keitel's son he was Asian
I haven't seen this movie in a long time
like the iconic things that I think up
or like Cheech Marin yeah like that
whole [ __ ] [ __ ] that's like one of
the best monologues like I want to
remember it I think that monologue and
just do it in like I favorite they're
just like a time right through casting
director they want me to have them all
off I want but he plays like three
people in that only place the Copley
come please the cop yeah I was into the
trailer and he also plays the place the
the person who they're making the deal
with at the end that's right yeah he's
[ __ ] awesome dude he into that [ __ ]
mall it was great that's one of the best
monologues in movie history I think and
I feel like more people show audition
with it like if you're trying to get
into that movie business
memorize that monologue and just use
that to audition I guarantee I'll get
work the makeup in the movie is awesome
because it's not like crazy visual
effects it's like straight-up practical
effects you know it's what what's the
word not puppetry is I forgot the word
for it I don't know you know like how
they used to do it back in the day where
it was just makeup you know yeah effect
makeup yeah I'm like full-on like latex
and just really doing like yeah it's not
so CG I think you know and that's what
made the makeup so [ __ ] scary in the
movie exactly it was all real designs so
it looked [ __ ] real as opposed to
like what they do nowadays with a lot of
like treat right like the old puppetry
of like if you go back to Star Wars like
Star Wars back in the day and looked so
good but yeah the puppets were made and
they looked really good and they were
actually like act exactly instead of
people acting towards tennis balls which
was the last doors everything was CGI so
everybody was acting towards right and
somebody reading off to the side how can
you forget the sexy ass dance by some
aha
the journal about Tarantino wrote for
himself the moment where she pours a
drink - yeah semi ice cast I got a new
scene than I'm running for it it is a
very seductive scene like it's a whole
dance whole song you are like I'm
getting turned on I'm like everyone else
in the movie I'm part of the crowd right
yes for although were the things that
put her on the map yeah for me
personally I mean I don't know what she
was doing before that but desperado I
was like wow this slays him and then
that movie just the sexiness went off
the handle oh dude yeah she was [ __ ]
amazing to look at Harvey Keitel too was
[ __ ] cool the movie his army
everything everything I am and I'm just
like all the way from taxi tag yeah like
taxi driver what he plays the pimp in
taxi driver I'm like this guy is I can't
take mine I didn't recognize him at
first when I saw it
oh really playing a pin yeah I didn't
recognize him at first in that I have
adventures like holy [ __ ] that's
probably good stuff I like about hard we
got on this cuz he's known for usually
playing like tough [ __ ] but in
that one it's like yeah he's a tough
[ __ ] by the end but he's you
know is a guy who you really feel the
pain of a dude who just lost his wife
he's a sensitive dude and he's he's a
father and everything you could also
feel this like anger inside of him it's
a great performance like really great
performance that's what's cool about
this film what really makes it work is
the fact that the performances were so
good - yeah beyond the unique directing
and style it was like the performances
are just [ __ ] on bar I feel like they
should they should do a linter and for
Liam Neeson Hollywood um jump on Harvey
Keitel and just write a bunch of like Oh
take attach things and like just write
up for Harvey Keitel because he could
play them and he loses himself in that
work Juliette Lewis
Julia Lewis oh she hasn't been around
and I do missing her she stopped cuz she
wanted to pursue music or something I
heard that years ago maybe because she
was like gonna be huge and then she just
sort of disappeared that well I hope
whatever world she's doing music and
she's huge amount she's great at acting
so oh and all from dusk till dawn got it
super duper right BAM yeah forgot that
we need a rating system good let's go
eight solid eight that's my reading
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
where we do [ __ ] you can find me at
Twitter on at Corbin underscore Kris or
watch Jane the virgin at 9:00 p.m. on
the CW on Mondays he's in it now yeah
he's in it play a real weird dude
yeah not far from real life
Oh comedy
James birch sent some weird photos here
are the photos guys I request a shout
out lol May please have a shout-out he
said some whale tail oh yeah apparently
this man is working in an event and he
has panties on oh [ __ ] yeah and it kind
us how to live now I would make fun of
the guy but he's black and I'm scared of
black people I want some racist oh I'm
like that guy is living his life he may
be doing the underneath his clothes but
he is living his life the way well I
mean good for him you know
so James birch dude you deserve a shout
out and he also said dick sucking
[ __ ] there's something about the word
[ __ ] that I don't agree I don't agree
I won't even say it because it's it's
simply wrong it's like the restaurant
gets every word and the sad thing is I
used to say it like as a teenager like
they didn't mean like you're just like
it just then I look back I'm like ooh I
feel like they did that back in the 50s
with another word and like they just
call each other that and it just was it
cool but dick sucking I do like dick
sucking well I don't like I've never
sucked it no I might have to Eric
Rodriguez shout out please you guys are
one of the few reasons I go on YouTube
nowadays username of mafia mafia I get
it mafia
Eric Rodriguez doing my Spanish brother
this guy is actually the son of Robert
Rodriguez
isn't no yeah Eric is he lives off his
daddy's fortune he's a spoiled little
brat doesn't do anything for his life
Eric is you know he's honestly daddy's
little [ __ ]
you never know I mean like he doesn't go
into YouTube nowadays so maybe it's just
like he has so much money that he can do
his own thing
that's not YouTube entertainment what
you got a fan still so that's great well
Eric you tell your dad Robert that I
said what's up and that one day him and
I are gonna work together and I'm not
looking forward to it Eddie Murray oh
well here we go hello my name is Eddie
requesting a shout-out from you guys I
love you our videos it brings joy to my
life as a cook at McDonald's I've it's
been a rough year so far and thanks you
guys especially Ryan I've dedicated it
to turn my life around start a career in
photography maybe even start a YouTube
channel so thanks again keep up the good
work by the way ELISA is hot didn't know
how to slide the common in there without
seeing me weird but hey who can blame
you sorry for this being long until I
understand if you don't read all of it
well I so did read all of it Eddie
Murray oh dude first off don't feel
shame for being a cook at McDonald's no
no [ __ ] love McDonald's I really do
it's delicious
number two delicious the number one Big
Mac [ __ ] awesome sometimes buy one
get one free after 9 p.m.
breakfast served at midnight I know the
[ __ ] menu too I'm glad that we could
help inspire you not sure how doing a
trailer reaction movie review channel
has really inspired you to go into
photography and I get it now I get it to
recognize my mind just clicked yeah dude
go for it start up your own channel let
me know and you're gonna come on this
channel yeah do you hear me you're gonna
come on this channel cross-promotions
baby cross-promotions that's what the
youtube world is all [ __ ] about let's
let's make a youtube society it really
is heartwarming when people say like we
inspired them in smashing
no I feels good and he did make it weird
when he started talking about ELISA but
you know what it's cool to make it weird
sometimes bro you can't blame him though
ELISA has like and I never seen her but
she has these huge tits and she she does
have a yeah she has a pretty face but
her tits are huge
and I'm sure guys look at that guys you
look at that I don't I'm kind of used to
them and I have a girlfriend that I'm
madly in love with yeah so naturally my
penis doesn't go though yeah and you're
married so that's a little bit higher
than what I'm involved in yeah so yeah